I think I talked a lot too last time you
you have some intentions of acting or
now no I can't act
I can't do it I love when a comic say
that how do you know I've failed I've
never gotten one audition I've gone on
nine million auditions ever gotten a
thing
can't do it I stink why do you do it
then ah you know you do it for the agent
and you go maybe I'll get this one it's
like a lotto ticket like so if you do
get what would you get nervous
not really I just don't give a [__] and
uh I never have gotten one so I've tried
everything
like acting coach I've got I've gotten
costumes I walk in with cowboy I go
howdy partner or whatever yeah I've got
an acting class I've done that that
didn't help yeah yeah I just can't act
I don't think I don't think that's it I
think what it is can I tell you about my
true opinion all right hit me okay if
they're not familiar with you yeah okay
because it's like if I was a producer
let's say one day I'm producing a movie
I would already know exactly where to
put you uh-huh right because there is a
tonality that you have right and a
rhythm that you have when you talk right
and I would put you in a specific place
but it's like if they're just strangers
to you and they're not familiar with
your work or who you are yes I think now
they're putting you against pitting you
against all the other white dudes yeah
right and they're like well let's see
how this guy does it not knowing your
your Rhythm the way you took because you
talk specific uh-huh yeah
kind of talking right right yeah I mean
oh boy kill myself
but no I think you're right they have no
idea who you are you coming and I sound
like a weird you think you sound like
it's not like Barry White or something
no I'm joking but uh yeah I think you're
right they're like who's this queef and
then I I'm not a good actor on top of
that so they go get him out of here yeah
it's because I went through the same
thing the things that I'm getting now
are people because they they know who
you are they know who I am and what I
bring and also the baggage that I bring
in many ways you know I mean they know
the whole thing so they're just like
this is what we want for this specific
thing but it's like you know um when
back in the day when I was just
auditioning for [__] and no one knew who
the [__] I was or even after Mad TV
because you know the industry didn't
watch it so they had no idea who I was
really right I mean so it was like it's
hard and it's heartbreaking I know
because you put in the work yeah yeah
but I wouldn't give up on it was what
I'm saying I don't also have a lot of
interest in it what am I gonna be in uh
you know Breaking Bad like I would I
would do curb because I love of Larry
Davis yeah that would be cool or like
it's always sunny or the office
something like that would be fun yeah
but I'm not going to be in the next
Scorsese
how do you know though ah I love when
people say that why why are you smiling
no I mean I get it like if it's just not
of like if you're not that interested
and if it's not a passion of yours I
think it's always for you yeah you want
to act and you're good at it you're
killing in Sex in the City my lady
watches it the show's terrible
it really is bad like the original was
so good yeah oh right and now it's just
it's almost like uh my lady has a theory
that it's all AI written that's not a
terrible yeah yeah you think it's AI
written the writing is so bad yeah I
think it's a uh or she thinks it's AI
well I can I I want to throw my because
I've never seen the past or the future
oh the old one was a killer yeah I never
saw the old one right wildly offensive
now if you watch it is it oh my God
there's one where she's like I kissed
the black guy
you know yeah it's very 90s yeah yeah
because it's the one show that I read
the dialogue and I don't know what
really any of it means right right right
so that I'm and then I'm in a spot like
I guess I'll try it this way yeah
because and every time I do it like a
rehearsal I could see them going
right so then they tell me what it how
to say it right they're like it's funny
yeah not a line reading but it's just
like just be more real about it yeah you
know what I mean and then that way I can
do it but it's like it's one of those
projects where I go I can't make a
choice here because I don't know what it
even means yeah you totally get that
when I look at a script I don't know
what they want me to do I have to get
someone to tell me what the motivation
is I'm so bad at it yeah I don't I can't
get it through the script I'm horrible
at acting in every Festival yeah yeah
but here's what you'll find though
because I think that you could do it
okay I'm not making you do it all right
and but also what I'm all gonna also say
is is that you are um
you know to be a white guy
um to be as young as you are right yeah
and I would say this about Sam as well
to break through in this competitive
market you have skills beyond the norm
okay there's something about you that's
um interesting wow okay I really do
believe that this is heavy right and I
know you don't like real talk no if it
hurts the compliments are weird yeah but
I'm gonna be real for a second oh God
's imitating me
what put the glasses down uh
let's be real for a second all right all
right because I want to get invited to
your next wedding I would love to have
you there yeah yeah yeah but just can
you just look at me right now and just
no don't do that all right it hurts when
I do it when I'm giving you a compliment
and you make offense like this it hurts
all right it hurts me right okay what
I'm saying though is is that it's a rare
thing
I'm listening spit it out will you I
will spit in my mouth yeah and it's it's
such a competitive market sure yeah I
look at you got you and Sam I think I
look at Taylor Tomlinson Sam's ex she's
very general very talented there's
certain white guys Trevor Wallace is
another one
um where I go you guys are just extra
something extra is going on and there's
something extra special you sound like a
white supremacist
white people I love them there's
something special about it yeah and
there's just something about you that's
so what I'm saying though is is that I
think that if with the right part you
would knock it out of the park and then
and here you don't know this yet but
what's cool about acting is people that
watch [__] like sex they don't
necessarily watch stand up or podcasts
that's true that is true so it's like
sometimes I'll walk around and people go
I love you a Magnum PI or I love you on
sex City reservation dogs Mad TV or
whatever whatever
right and it's like it's just an extra
tool to use to get more fans in right
and sometimes they'll come to my shows
and go we never got them to shows but we
love you on the show so much I mean and
we want to support but it's we loved it
whatever whatever but my point is is
that you don't know but I get what
you're saying okay all right and you're
special uh and you're the best and I
love you so much I think you're a great
guy
what about me okay
[Laughter]
what is that about Comics I can't do it
well it just feels weird
it's a lot I can't even look someone in
the eye yeah you notice I'm going
right down the middle here between you
two yeah cause I don't want to be rude
but and as he's doing that to you I'm
getting second hand discomfort too so
I'm looking down and twirling